in the middle of all the craziness of
the last couple days
this next story really didn't get the
attention that it deserves
Donald Trump has this interim attorney
general Matthew Whitaker this is the guy
I've previously told you said that only
Christians should be federal judges this
is the guy who in the past has outlined
as a private citizen of course exactly
how he would interfere with the Trump
Russia probe if given the chance and he
gave a couple of days ago a bizarre and
confused and I guess rambling would be
the other adjective I would apply to it
bizarre confused and rambling speech
while sweating profusely and he lets
things slip during this speech that are
really odd so pay very close attention
to what he says which we'll talk about
shortly but also notice both if you're
just listening but also if you're
watching the really strange demeanor and
dynamics of his speech you know I've
been fully briefed on the investigation
and you know I look forward to director
Muller delivering the final report and I
really am NOT going to talk about open
and ongoing investigation otherwise but
you know sort of the statements that I
made where as a private citizen only
with publicly available information and
I you know I am I am comfortable that
the decisions that were made are going
to be reviewed
you know either through the various
means we have but right now you know the
investigation is I think close to being
completed and I hope that we can get the
report from director Muller as soon as
we as possible he truly doesn't seem to
know what he's talking about he doesn't
seem to know what he's saying it seems
like one of those moments where the
brain becomes disconnected from the
mouth and things just come out so when
he says he's been fully briefed on the
investigation by whom and to what degree
like what what exactly is he talking
about when he says he's been fully
briefed about the investigation
everything he said before about how he
would end and interfere with the
investigation forget about all of that
stuff he says because those were
comments that he made
as a private citizen but the most
disturbing thing that he said here which
again it this is not getting nearly the
attention it deserves he said that he's
comfortable that the decisions that were
made with regard to the investigation
are going to be reviewed what on earth
does that mean Pat who is going to
review them for what purpose what what
is he talking about what does that even
mean well he is technically Robert
Muller's boss that's the crazy world
that we live in so maybe he has been
personally briefed but I suspect that he
hasn't and he's talking out of as you
know what and then he gets to the
investigation is close to being
completed it didn't even really seem
like he was trying to say that he sort
of stuttered in a very strange way we
know that we haven't had any any leaks
from Muller about when the
investigations going to be over would
Muller even considering that yes and
some harebrained in horrible ways Pat
points out Whitaker is Muller's boss
would Muller have said to Matthew
Whitaker that he's almost done is
Whitaker guessing that the investigation
is almost over is he hoping that it's
almost over
is he trying to by saying this publicly
push the investigation to actually and
soon Whitakers involvement in the
Justice Department has just been a train
wreck from day one everything related to
the guy is weird and as far as this
investigation ending soon thing that he
said deliberately are not deliberately
truthfully or untruthfully Whitaker's
wife is named Marci Whitaker she
recently emailed a reporter from Slate
to tell him that his article is bad and
wrong and also to assert that the Moller
investigation is wrapping up those were
the words that Marci Whitaker said to a
member of the media that the Moller
investigation is wrapping up how would
Matthew Whitaker's wife know that even
if it's true that's extraordinarily
inappropriate whether it's true or not
Marci Whitaker doesn't work in
government she doesn't have a security
clearance so if she's lying and just
emailing reporters that the
investigations going to end when she
actually doesn't know anything about
that that's inappropriate but if Matthew
Whitaker has told his wife things that
aren't available to the public that
criminal okay just imagine for a second
here if the roles were reversed and it
was I don't know Hillary Clinton
Attorney General and you had her husband
Bill Clinton emailing reporters with
information that was at that point
unknown to the public they would be
calling for her immediate imprisonment
Pat and yet here we have Matthew
Whitaker in way over his head without
the slightest idea what's going on
what's appropriate and as far as the
probe is ending maybe he's right maybe
he's not but there is something very
wrong going on here well the upside is
that Matthew Whitaker will only be the
acting Attorney General for another week
or two the downside is that his
replacement William Barr he expressed
that he's not going to interfere with
the Muller investigation but Democrats
can't get a straight answer as to
whether he'll release the full report to
the public and that we really got to
know William Barr could be just as bad
yeah this is now becoming the new
question which is okay allowing an
investigation to go on is correct it's
fine it's sort of like a baseline it
shouldn't even be a question as to
whether the Attorney General is going to
interfere with ongoing investigations
but then the question is are we going to
be able to see the results of that
investigation and he has played very
very coy and avoided just giving a
straight answer on that during his
confirmation hearings will the
investigation and soon I don't know I
mean every three to four weeks we see
articles claiming molars almost done and
those articles date all the way back to
almost two years ago in 2017 we know we
haven't seen leaks from Muller I
questioned whether molar would go to
Whitaker and say I'm about to be done
maybe Muller did do that but on the
other hand when I see that the FBI
conducts a pre-dawn raid on Trump
associate Roger stone so that he can't
destroy evidence as the FBI shows up
that doesn't signal to me that the
investigation is close to done it would
strike me as a signal that there's still
work to be done here the truth is we
don't know the reality is there have not
actually been any leaks from Robert
Muller as far as that goes so we'll have
to wait and see but what is very very
clear
is that Matthew Whitaker is in way over
his head he doesn't know what he's
talking about and it's a good thing that
he's going to be out sooner than later
then we become concerned about his
replacement and that really is a problem
make sure you're following me on
instagram at david hackman where i just
announced some new upcoming public
speaking engagements that i will be
doing maybe one will be coming to your
city or town or indoctrinated liberal
college campus who knows follow me on
instagram at david pakman make sure you
follow the david pakman show on
instagram also at david pakman show
former NFL football player Arian Foster
joins me next to talk about is Tom Brady
the greatest of all time we get through
that topic very quickly as my prediction
we will also talk about his leaving
religion and becoming an atheist the
National Anthem protests by football
players and much much more Arian Foster
joins me next today's sponsor is
Skillshare and I'm excited to tell you
that everybody in our audience is
getting two entire months of free access
to Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video skill shares the
site that offers over 25,000 online
courses on almost any topic you can
imagine cooking meditation photography
video editing Photoshop managing a small
business almost an endless list and
whether you're trying to get ahead in
your career maybe you want to learn new
skills that will make you better at your
job you might just be exploring a new
hobby and you're trying to find new ways
to be creative in your personal time
skill shares the perfect place to fully
immerse yourself in whatever you're
trying to learn I really enjoyed the
class on more advanced video editing
techniques because it's something I've
been wanting to improve at but have been
very busy hosting the david packard show
for the last few years
once again the david pakman show is
giving you two whole months of access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
after those two months if you want to
keep your subscription Skillshare super
affordable at
than 10 bucks a month get better at
whatever it is that you're passionate
about or discover something brand-new
that you didn't even know that you would
love and join skill shares other 7
million users by clicking the link
underneath this video
[Music]